hello everyone and welcome to another
game you guys requested as soon as it
finished it's from round five of the
oslo esports cup it's magnus carlsen
versus jordan fun for esta and um uh
well it's uh it's definitely a big deal
since jordan is one of his uh seconds
from the world chess championship match
against dianne ponishi and he knows uh
what carlsen knows very very well but um
also to some degree vice versa uh so
we'll see who wins the
uh the uh
um well the the the preparation duel uh
but uh even after that it's gonna get
very crazy so let's dive straight into
it there is quite a lot to enjoy uh
magnus opens with c4 he goes for the
english uh opening with e5 by jordan the
sort of king's english variation e3 we
have knight to f6 uh knight to c3 and
now d5 striking in the center c captures
knight captures uh and now magnus plays
queen to h5 the uh move from the
thumbnail and although it seems like a
very weird move to play uh magnus
actually played it um uh
two years ago against nakamura in the
saint louis um blitz tournament uh and
also uh there is another gentleman who
played it daniel dubose so it's a it's a
known move and if you are uh facing the
uh the english you have to be ready for
it so here we have knight to c6
continuing development and now bishop to
b5 pinning the knight and now we are
ready to play queen captures on e5 uh
and here
uh in the game that i've mentioned dubo
versus silicef do we played queen to d6
to
defend the e5 pawn but here we have
knight to b4 uh going after that c2
square to deliver check also uh
defending this night uh and we now uh
transpose into the game magnus carlsen
versus hikaru nakamura from the saint
louis blitz tournament 2020. uh queen
captures an e5 with check as the knight
of course is pinned bishop to e6 and now
uh queen to a4
uh here we have a6 challenging the
bishop bishop back to e2 and now comes
queen to d7 uh here nakamura played
bishop to e7 but uh it still uh
was uh not his game he and magnus was
able to win this one but here we have
queen to d7 by jordan and it is now as
of move nine that we have a completely
new game uh so let's see how magnus
tackles this new territory he plays a3
uh now the queen guards the c2 square so
that's not an issue uh f5 before moving
the knight you could go to d5 but f5 is
um uh to be preferred queen back to b1
we still have to keep an eye on the c2
square knight to d5 and not knight to f3
magnus continues development we have
queen side castles uh and now b4 magnus
starts his expansion and he wants to put
a bishop on b2 uh try uh creating some
uh attacking chances uh by pushing the
pawns later on so here g5 uh as uh
carlson's king is still in the center of
the board most likely he will castle
king's side so it makes sense to prepare
our pawns um uh for the uh
uh for pushing and capturing on g5 isn't
all that impressive we're just gonna
play captures and see three d captures
and bishop to c4 and already you can see
how it's very very difficult for white
to even castle you can't castle because
the bishop hangs and if you capture the
bishop then queen d1 will be checkmate
so not something you want to go into so
after g5 we have castles by magnus he
uh realized that the danger is lurking
everywhere and now g4 by ordon we have
knights to g5 attacking the bishop and
bishop back the g8 with bishop to b2 by
magnus now if the knight moves it could
be very scary so bishop to g7 we have to
counter white's a stronger bishop on b2
and now knight to a4 offering a trade of
bishops but now instead of trading we
have knight to f4 by jordan and here the
position completely explodes uh what is
happening here and how can white
continue the game
uh is the knight uh up for grabs that's
uh that that's a good question now
bishop captures on g4 believe it or not
is the absolute strongest move
recommended by the engine but we are not
going to discuss this one as it said
it's you know uh
such a
disgusting engine line is is too much
even for me to show in a rapid game so
here e captures an f4 was played by
magnus and now we have the shop captures
on b2 uh and now uh it all depends what
magnus plays so feel free to pause the
video here and try to figure out the
winning move for magnus while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
crazy idea and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is knight to
c5 that's the good stuff we attack the
queen and also we add another attacker
to black's queen side and this will be
uh well this would be incredibly
incredibly difficult to stop so here
jordan played queen captures on d2 and
now now comes the move that magnus had
to play in order to continue because
knight to c5 is the correct way but now
you have to play bishop captures an a6
uh and we we are going to show this one
the idea is that after bishop captures
an a6 now you're just threatening to
pick pick up on b7 as well so b captures
and only now queen captures an f5 with
check king b8 knight captures an a6 and
now it doesn't really matter where the
king goes to you can't go here if you go
here then queen to b5 is deadly if you
go here then we're just going to
continue checking queen c5 check king
captures queen captures and after let's
see king a7 now we play queen a4 check
gaining control over the d1 square uh so
now all both rooks and the queen control
the d1 square and after the king moves
wherever rook a to d1 just wins the game
on the spot after the queen moves of
course we gobble up the rook or you give
up the queen but it will be insufficient
uh for example queen captures rook
captures let's zero capture screen
captures this is uh
uh not nearly enough material to play
this so instead after queen captures on
d2 magnus doesn't play the absolute best
bishop captures on a6 he plays rook to
a2
because he says all right this is of
course very interesting most likely
winning but why not just uh you know
improve my position first but he
completely blunders that the bishop on
b8 is actually on g8 is actually uh
guarding the a2 square so jordan just
picks up the rook bishop captures an a2
and now magnus ghost for queen captures
an f5 it looks very scary but it is now
not enough king b8 bishop captures on a6
magnus plays it now but now knight to d4
attacking the queen queen captures sanji
for now b captures an a6 knight captures
an a6 with czech king the a7 and even
knight captures on c7 uh and now uh
after jordan played queen to e2 it was
in this position on move 25 uh that
magnus carlson resigned in the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
now you might uh you might be thinking
well okay the black king is completely
uh
i mean he's completely in the open here
there are no pawns uh
in front of it there basically aren't
all that many pieces in front of it
couldn't we use maybe our pawns the
knight the queen to somehow put pressure
on the black king instead of just
resigning here you could if this was not
winning by force now the problem is the
queen has no
uh the queen has no good squares for
example if you play queen to g3 uh it's
uh just a very sad move uh uh
or just a very very sad square for for
the queen uh and uh well we can even
just play queen captures in f1 and after
king captures an f1 bishop to c4 check
and now you can see if you go back to g1
knight to e2 is just deadly so you're
gonna have to play queen to d3 but now
of course if we play queen to d3 you
know that that's game over but here you
don't just win the queen you actually
deliver checkmate with with rook to d1
so queen g3 doesn't work because of this
checkmate and queen the h4
doesn't work again because of this
checkmate
uh here uh we're still gonna play queen
captures on f1 and there is nothing you
can do here king captures on f1 bishop
to c for check king the g1 now just runs
into knights the e2 check king to f1 and
the rook to d1 will be checkmate so
that's a problem for magnus uh and of
course uh he saw this and he didn't want
to allow jordan this opportunity to uh
finish the game in a brilliancy because
uh he blundered and he feels that that
is maybe enough uh for jordan to grab a
full point here
uh so after this queen to e2 magnus
resigned and a wonderful victory for
jordan van forest with the black pieces
in round two uh of the uh of the uh uh
oslo esports cup and uh yeah i mean it
happens to everyone here it happened to
magnus it's just uh incredible i mean
you prepare everything you do everything
right you you have to you play knight c5
you have to continue uh playing
brilliant chess and then you play rook
to a2 and yes everyone thinks this only
happens to you but here you can see it
can also happen to a world chess
champion so just putting your rook in
front of a bishop that's it
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh very very crazy lines in
this one thank you for suggesting it so
so very quickly uh i would like to thank
dk benjamin uh marco galassi fred
ackerman uh joseph uh
verasuria and robert aratune for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the chess
world uh so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day